[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday October 3rd I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
for many companies cloud computing was
sold to them as a cost-effective way to
store data and quickly scale up or down
their it capabilities and many Chief
technology and information officers
across Industries got on board but now
many are feeling the cost savings they
were promised haven't really paid off
according to a survey from KPMG roughly
two-thirds of a thousand senior Tech
leaders at U.S firms say they've yet to
see a significant return on their Cloud
Investments so where does that leave
companies and what does it mean for the
future of the cloud joining us to
discuss is Wall Street Journal CIO
Journal reporter Isabelle bousquet hi
Isabelle thanks for joining me yeah
thank you so much Zoe so why are costs
higher than ctOS expected yeah I think
there's a few reasons for that the first
one is that companies rushed to cloud
with not a lot of strategic thinking
about where they were going to put
certain applications or how much data
they were actually going to need on the
cloud and it was sort of this mad push
over the past decade that was
accelerated a law by the pandemic as
well to just get as much on cloud as
fast as possible sometimes they were
paying for the same thing on two
different clouds and they didn't
necessarily maybe need everything they
were paying for or they were processing
data in multiple places and not really
doing things in an optimal way
take us back a bit I mean 10 years ago
when the kind of first push for
migrating onto the cloud was happening
what was the pitch that cloud providers
were making to businesses
essentially the idea behind cloud is
that instead of paying for your own
on-premise data center as a place where
you're gonna host all your data and all
your applications you would essentially
rent server space from companies like
Amazon or Microsoft and the pitch was
essentially that you would only pay for
what you use and that was a really
helpful way to scale up and down
especially to meet surges and demands
that weren't necessarily expected I
think Black Friday might be a good
example for like retail companies if
you're seeing a major Russian traffic to
your website and you're on the cloud the
cloud will automatically scale up to
meet that demand and at the same time if
you have a week where maybe you're not
getting a lot of traffic you're not
paying for the amount of compute
capacity you would need if you were
getting a lot of traffic and then as
time has gone on there have been a lot
of other capabilities later on top of
that a lot to do with AI and and being
able to do cool analytics on top of the
data that you're keeping in the cloud
and I think in the early days of cloud
as well there was this idea that you
would choose one of the cloud providers
and they would kind of be your main
cloud and so a lot of companies built
applications that were specific to the
main Cloud they were using and as time
went on they realized that
there are certain applications or
certain capabilities that different
Cloud providers offer and they really
wanted to be able to use certain
capabilities from various Cloud
providers not just one and they didn't
want to be locked in
so I think then as they started using
more Cloud providers they realized that
oh no a lot of the applications we built
specifically for what we thought was
going to be our main cloud provider we
now have to rebuild and and that's where
a lot of the costs came in as well so on
that note I mean what steps are
businesses taking to reduce their costs
one is just like some clouds have tier
systems so basically companies that put
everything on the highest tier of cloud
capabilities can take a step back and
realize well maybe some of these things
can be on a lower tier maybe we don't
need the highest tier of compute
capability the other piece is really
just around interoperability of multiple
Cloud providers and making sure that
they don't have duplication across
clouds making sure they're not paying
for the same thing twice do we expect to
see companies do a total reversal maybe
pull these things off of the cloud and
just start holding their own data again
no I don't think we're gonna see that
necessarily happening I think what we're
in now is I would almost call it like a
second phase of cloud migration that's a
little bit more measured and a little
bit more strategic and
um companies just understand a little
bit more about what the costs can be
here year and and how high they can be
and I think that's something they didn't
really understand in the first phase of
cloud migration that was sort of just a
mad rush so what's the Outlook then for
the cloud industry
so still a lot of interest in the cloud
companies still think the cloud is the
future and it's definitely the place to
be but there's not that huge massive
surging in demand that we were seeing
say at the beginning of the pandemic and
I think another part of that that's
maybe important to acknowledge is just
what's going on with the economy right
now you know there's been a lot of talk
about whether it budgets are going to be
slashed if we enter into a recession and
I.T leaders are going to be under more
pressure to demonstrate the return on
investment alright that's our reporter
Isabel busquet thanks for joining us
Isabel yeah thanks so much again Zoe and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
if you want more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]